big news today as Wall Street is bracing
for a US trade war with China that would
hurt American companies farmers and
consumers a sharp decline in the Dow
Jones Industrial Average is expected
this morning China is expected to
retaliate against new US tariffs that
began on Friday the Trump administration
is already preparing more tariffs on
nearly all Chinese goods President Trump
tweeted yesterday quote we are right
where we want to be with China Ben Tracy
just returned from a two-year assignment
in Beijing so he's just the man to have
at the White House following the trade
battle Ben good morning good morning so
the Chinese are vowing to take what
they're calling necessary
countermeasures that could include
tariffs on US products they could also
make life very difficult for US
companies doing business in China in a
series of tweets this morning President
Trump seems to be doubling down on his
belief that only China will be heard in
this trade war but now his own advisors
are contradicting him both sides will
pay lighthouse economic advisor Larry
Kudlow admitted Sunday what nearly every
economist knows to be true the tariffs
President Trump is imposing on Chinese
goods imported into the u.s. are not
solely paid for by the Chinese but it's
US businesses and US consumers who pay
correct yes to some extent again both
sides both sides will suffer on this on
Friday President Trump slapped a 25
percent tariff on approximately 200
billion dollars worth of Chinese imports
and is now ordering his trade
representatives to start the paperwork
to tariff an additional 300 billion
dollars basically everything China sends
to the US from cell phones to furniture
it's a fight the president says he's
worth having
so our country can take in a hundred and
twenty billion dollars a year in tariffs
paid for mostly by China by the way not
by US tariffs do make Chinese goods more
expensive which can hurt China's economy
but the actual tariffs are a tax paid by
US companies that import Chinese
products companies can either take on
those costs and make less money or they
raise prices on US consumers which is
what often happens but President Trump
isn't just battling China on the world
stage he's also at war with Congress
Democrats have launched more than 20
separate investigations into President
Trump his actions as president
his personal finances and his
administration's policies the Democrats
are more interested in subpoenas than
solutions on Face the Nation Republican
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
criticized Democrats for what isn't
getting done we want to move forward
we got health care we got trade we got a
crisis on our border and while Democrats
say they can multitask don't think that
we can't do both
even on a bipartisan issue like
infrastructure so far there's been no
concrete legislative progress president
Trump seems to be relishing the fight it
was a rainy in chilly Sunday here in
Washington and that may account for the
more than dozen tweets he sent out he
called Democrats nuts and crazed
lunatics and said the real
constitutional crisis is Democrats
refusing to work John all right Ben
Tracy at the White House Thank You Ben